[Musique]
la mort plane au dessus du village de
saint-élie-de-caxton
écrit leconte l'arracheuse de temps
alors qu'il était lui-même en deuil mon
père est mort subitement ils étaient en
net retrait en santé tout à coup il a
planché certains étaient tellement mort
subite puis fait que j'avais des comptes
à régler avec la mort moi j'ai eu un
deuil de colère quand mon père est mort
une colère qui le sublimer en beauté
dans l'arracheuse de temps bernadette la
grand-mère malade du betty fred tente de
le rassurer sur son sort pour lui
racontant une histoire qui s'est passé
au village en 1927 lecomte a toujours
servi à ça je pense a nommé justement
les choses qui étaient plutôt
mystérieuse qui faisait peur pour les
enfants et pour les adultes
on retrouve toute une galerie de
personnages extraordinaires fantastique
mais extraordinairement vrai et qui
malgré leurs imperfections véhicule de
belles valeurs
il faut s'entraider
pour moi c'était qui ressort le plus de
films qui nous laisse la fantaisie ce
soit des gens qui sont réelles je pense
que cela permet à la fois émouvant et
caves oui je dois sorcières au centre de
l'histoire beaucoup de femmes fortes et
de convictions comme bernadette la
grand-mère de fred que la comédienne
jeanne charbonneau un quart du temps de
sa jeunesse mais premièrement faire la
grand-mère de fred pellerin une danse
c'est un cadeau énorme
c'est une jeune femme qui est que
beaucoup de force qu'ils quitteraient
très téméraire est très intelligente
puis je trouve que ça fait du bien de
voir une jeune femme comme ça au cinéma
le réalisateur francis leclerc parvis à
transposer à l'écran et mon merveilleux
et fantaisistes comme on en voit
rarement cinéma québécois bien eu des
films quand même au québec qui sont
frôlés au fantastique wade des films de
genre puisque souvent c'est boboche
parce qu'on n'a pas d'argent puis moi
c'était comme une condition c'est qu'on
aille les moyens de faire ces femmes là
comme du monde
erwan on retrouve avec plaisir toute la
truculence des personnages et de
l'univers de fred pellerin et on peut
voir un show d'humour
[Musique]
souvent voir fred pallem ceux qui seront
l'arracheuse de temps prouve que la mort
d'un être cher peut coïncider avec la
naissance d'une belle légende ici nabi
avec cendres chartier radio canada
montréal